getting back to uh what Jaren was saying
like the one case that always screws me
up is like Arnold with his uh like he
blew his whole life up for that cleaning
lady
yeah he was married to basically a
Kennedy yeah yeah and he had all like
she never went back after that like
there's a certain degree of
embarrassment that like women won't
tolerate like if it was kind of quiet
and under the radar and it never really
you know got exposed publicly she would
have probably just stuck with it and
just looked the other way but when he
knocked up like the like literally the
most unattractive person that's also the
cleaning lady in your house that's got
to be a big blow to her ego and she had
really no choice but to leave him right
but I don't get it because the guy had
game like I don't know if you ever watch
pumping Iron the guy had like yeah the
pump is like coming yeah like yeah
I think I know what happened
I think I know what happened like Arnold
has been on gear or that's what I was
thinking he runs so hot all the time
yeah but when you're on gear you can't
get a girl pregnant so I don't
understand how oh you can who told you
that why well I've got plenty of
bodybuilders who thought that and
they're like oh here's the surprise
eggs
on trt and I used to be on a cruise and
I had two women pregnant
okay so I found a picture
um of the cleaning lady this looks like
a more recent picture so probably not
when he was smashing but this is his
yeah like what this is his board yeah I
can guarantee you yeah that's her there
had given enough trembolone you will
look
at a [ __ ] doorknob
let me see if I can find it look at his
son with her it's like the most carbon
copy of all these kids yeah
um
let me see if I can find a picture of
her when when they actually you know
did the deed because because I I don't
think that picture's completely fair to
her because the kid's like 20 years old
there I'm just wondering if there's
anything where she looks like you know
remotely okay uh I was gonna say because
sometimes you'll get sometimes you'll
get a really cute cleaning lady come
through uh where I live on the Mexico
City everyone has cleaning ladies you
have people that pretty much just serve
you and every now and then you'll get a
real cutie that comes through but this
chick yeah I don't know he's right he
must have been running hot and that's
when he was like in his Peak movie star
career right 20 years ago whatever it
was like he was like Pete Arnold yeah
yeah
um I can give it to you in writing that
given enough gear you could get around
my desk I'm not I'm not finding anything
here that does her better justice so I I
think it's reasonable to say that you
know what you see is what you get but
yeah that's that's yeah that would have
been a huge blow to
um
what's her name is
um Maria Shriver yeah that's it that's
it there's one of those days maybe he
was stressed out riled up needed a quick
release before he went on set or
something he's like ah you know you'll
you'll do
she must have you know how women can
come at you when they really want you
you know when they really want the seed
you know how they come at you right
yeah she must have played some very loud
game on him for you'll be like okay fine
yeah yeah we don't talk about girl games
yeah
I don't know that just it blows my mind
because he could have anyone he wants
and he picked that
I don't think he picked her
she's that she was there there yeah yeah
she was just there yeah I would imagine
she probably chased him down for for a
bit he just sold it he's like yeah okay
fine just bear wrestled them down the
the greatest
[Laughter]
hey guys I really hope that you enjoyed
that short clip if you did consider
supporting the creation of content by
checking out my supplement line pinned
in the top comment below of this video
in the comments there's a link to the
unpluggedalpha.com forward slash shop
when you click through you'll be able to
land over here and the entire lineup is
broken down by category that it performs
best in estrogen metabolism fat burning
your foundational Essentials for health
immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out